the number one reason I build massive
scale is I have zero interest in
convincing anyone I've shut down three
minutes into a business pitch if
someone's out they're out that energy
for me to try to get them in is not
interesting I'm even more conscious that
I don't want to be rude because I don't
want to think anybody that I'm big
timing you I'll sit through the meeting
but my brain shut off three minutes in
when I'm like they're out because I have
nothing in me and not because I've been
even when I was a kid trying to sell
wine I'd rather take that energy and
build leverage with someone else or do
the thing that will make them in
convincing is the worst game in the
world and it's the game the majority of
people in business play